My name is Fuka Haruna.
People call me Harukaze-chan online.
I am in the 6th grade and I'm also an actress.
My mom gave me a mobile phone when I was three,...
...so she could reach me while she was at a driving school.
So, I really grew up with it.
I started using Twitter when I was nine to promote one of my works.
It since become a big family of followers.
I received some harsh comments and they do hurt my feelings.
I used to cry alone in my room especially when they wrote bad things about my family.
But, I still love to communicate with my followers,...
...and I hope as long as I reply sincerely,...
I can be friends even with some of my critics.
Meet 27-year-old Taichi Hirano.
By any standard, he's a typical Japanese youth.
By day, he works as a nurse, taking care of seniors.
But by night, he's leading rallying cries...
...against the use of nuclear energy in Japan.
He says it was the accident at the Fukushima Nuclear Power Plant in March last year,...
...that woke up his otherwise shy personality.
Even before the 3/11 incident,...
...I vaguely knew that nuclear energy could be dangerous.
But, I was hesitant to attend demonstrations...
...because I didn't know what to expect.
But, when I watched the explosion at the nuclear power plants in Fukushima,...
...and how they've been affecting local communities,...
...I decided I needed to speak up.
Well, tens of thousands of people have been gathering in Kasumigaseki,...
...where many government buildings are every Friday.
As you can see, there are many young people in their 20s and 30s....
...including some children, protesting against the government's decision...
...to restart nuclear reactors.